Thank You Sandra and the thanks
organizer for sibling such great
foregrounds a real pleasure to be here
okay so I'm going to talk about secure
multi-party computation most of you are
familiar with the commonly used acronym
it's just too long MPC somewhat oddly
MPC is used in the literature to denote
everything secure multi-party
computation and I don't know if you ever
thought about it but it seems I'm always
bothered by me abate and it always seems
to me like a poor choice of acronym but
then I realized that that - actually
this economy is very very important
advantages first you know if you ever
realized that there is a bug in your
security proof or no security proof at
all it puts you in a kind of a better
legal situation and in the second point
which is actually a serious one you know
if if you ever get to review a paper
that contains a more appropriate acronym
like especially anonymous crypto
submissions right that contain a more
corporate acronym like a SMC or SM PC
then you know it was written by pedantic
authors who cannot be any of your
friends so the paper can be safely
rejected so it may be the first
take-home message from this talk is that
it's sometimes better to use the
standard if more inappropriate acronym
than this okay anyway I'm not going to
change the acronym and I hope that
somebody will a will will take the
initiative and change it but I'm
sticking with MPC okay so I'm going to
start with a gentle introduction to MPC
just to test the grounds how many people
here are not familiar with the basic
notion okay so it seems like almost
everyone is familiar and then you can
use it as a way to introduce to have a
gentle introduction to MPC to other
people but anyway I'll try to be cool
it'll be quick
I will try to give
some idea of the breadth of definitions
of the NPC is some idea about protocols
I will talk about open problems and
luckily for everyone why we will never
run out of them and obviously it's it's
a very you know big big area and the any
such survey talk has to focus on a small
selection of issues I try to combine
between giving some broad overview in
some parts of the talk and in other
parts focusing on things that obviously
biased by my own research but please
feel free to ask questions about
everything or to stop me or on any
issues that you'd like to hear more
about okay so let me start with this
claim please don't try to think about it
too hard its circular it might mess with
your brain is in the mix talk so but
really you know even even those of us
who are used to working on this problem
often forget that you know if we take
this problem in its fullest generality
as has been defined in the literature it
can actually capture problems that don't
we don't think of them like MPC right so
error correcting codes you can cast it
as an instance of MPC with a certain you
know type of security distributed
algorithms right it's like MPC without
the secrecy requirement again you can
cast it as an instance of the general
problem in oceans from complexity theory
like interactive proofs pc ps1 domestics
factors basically to graphic primitives
that we do not think of them as being
npc can also be cast into this framework
so basically anything that you can
phrase as protecting good guys against
bad guys this framework is general
enough to to capture it so you know if
you kind of hate this area and you
secretly wish that you know it will
vanish in a few years then I have
can you have been useful for you the
government government will bail it out
when we function I don't know I mean you
can always generalize but again it is an
attempt to general especially people
like one Canadians in pushing this
agenda that you can generalize in
general that of course you can say the
same about logic right it's not so the
fact that the language is general
doesn't mean that you know you need to
think about it in this way but it just
means that we'll never this is actually
the answer to the last point in the
previous slide this is why we can never
run out of problems when we figure out
all of these things you know it
completely then we may run out of MPC
questions but because it's so broadened
and has so many highly non-trivial
special cases that fill the entire
communities we can never run out of open
questions that's one answer to this
question okay so in the rest of the talk
I will talk mainly focus on what most of
us think about when we hear MPC namely
the goal of securely evaluating a
function in let's again go quickly over
this very simple two example where let's
say that we want to to figure out or
actually six of us because the picture
only contains six parties I want to
figure out or effort salary or
equivalently the sum of our salaries or
relatively you know maybe more
interesting here to figure out what is
the average travel reimbursement we
received from the assignment institution
okay so yeah so we want to compute the
sum of our you know secret local inputs
without revealing anything else to each
other to the extent possible this is the
simple special solution take someone we
all love in traffic
kymmie for those know him I hope this
does not put me in trouble but anyway
I'm not recorded so if I recorded if
we're not it will not be on the internet
and if it's if it's on the internet it's
beyond the reach of North Korean hackers
I know I'm fine anyway I love him
seriously you can really do it for us
assuming that we all trust him okay and
the goal of MPC is to find a better way
if we don't have here in the u.s. we
don't have anyone with L trustful so we
need to find other ways this is updated
this is updated because moving to the
Bay Area but let's assume that there is
way did anyone here receive the travel
reimbursement of more than ten billion
dollars okay so we're fine so let's
assume that the answer is a bounded by
this Capital m and and now from now on
all addition and subtraction operations
are taken what to do him okay so how do
we do it right so I know a I guess that
even people who study or do research in
MPC are not necessarily aware of the
simple of these very simple example so
here is this very simple old protocol
believe it should be attributed to charm
or it's kind of equivalent to what Shawn
did and so the first guy you know picks
a random number modulo n which he uses
to mask his input and send it to the
second the second girl so he sends a
method which is just his input plus our
module M she sends to the third guy this
message plus her input and so on each
party adds his or her input - whatever
it received from the previous party
now the last party receives the sum plus
his original mass car so we can just
unmask by subtracting our from the
result okay so it's clear that we get
the right result what about what can we
say about the security of this protocol
right and I'm assuming that everybody is
following the protocol there are no
malicious parties here so if this
protocol is secured against any single
party what do you think so is there a
single party that can learn anything
except the sum of the inputs and
whatever follows from his or her input
so this protocol in fact right so that
this is how it ends so this protocol
actually is secure against any single
party because every party what it can
see except for the final message if we
look at some some party in the middle
then it just gets a completely random
element of Z M and the last the only
message received by the first guy is the
sum is the sum of all inputs which is
the outputs that we must reveal a plus
the randomness the T picked right so
clearly no information is revealed to
anyone any single party beyond the Sun
but if you look at two colluding parties
like the first and the third
they can easily unmask the second input
therefore compromising completely
compromising the privacy of the second
party this is a simple example that's
even useful it's used something similar
it's called DC net and is used to
implement anonymity and you can you can
actually get around it's easy to get
around the previous insecurity by just
using more elaborate Network so we we
just take a complete graph in directed
edges arbitrarily so this is the
tournament graph now every party
for each outgoing age it Peaks an
independent random group element and
sends it to the destination of this edge
okay so this defines the entire
communication in the first round okay we
have n choose two six choose two
messages here now what happens in the
second round each party does the local
computation where he takes its own input
adds all the Inbox all the incoming
messages and subtracts all the outgoing
messages all of the outbox okay and this
is what every party broadcasts who
everyone sends out to everyone okay so
it it's clear that if we take so in the
second message in the second round we
have six messages if we add them up then
every random ask will cancel out because
it appears in exactly one in books in
one outbox okay now you can analyze this
and show that this protocol assuming
that everybody follows it follows it is
indeed secure against any subset of
parties and more generally you know it's
a nice exercise in linear algebra to
show that if you could you can use
partial graphs in the combinatorial
criterion is that whenever said there's
no to disconnect the rest of the graph
if you ignore the directions from the
edges then the protocol is secure
against this set of colluding parties so
you can use like expanded of sparse
graphs to to get good solutions to this
Bo okay so more generally now this this
video click calls for the generalization
and I guess I should be very quick here
because you know if somebody wants more
details on anything because this stuff
really I believe that everyone
understands at least the intuitive level
so we have the K parties that want to
compute some arbitrary function f of
their inputs before it was a sum a
modular sum now it's a general function
we have a property that measures how
many parties can collude and we want
them to learn essentially nothing except
the output and we refer to this as a
security protocol here I got it wrong it
should be MPC protocol for it okay so
that too
so questions one can ask the first is
when can we at all do it you know at any
cost
and the second is how efficiently if we
can do it then we want to understand how
efficiently so this is just kind of
Erika before defining anything formally
this is pretty much the same in almost
every reasonable setting for secure
computation there are some exceptions
but this is pretty much the state of the
art whether we're talking about passive
or active attacks that I will define
later so in the eighties we have we had
this these amazing feasibility results
and they showed us that if we want
information theoretic security like in
the previous protocol then we can do it
in general if and only if we have an
honest majority so as long as they we
have less than K over two out of the K
participants are corrupted we think of
them as being corrupted by an adversary
in the case of computational security
okay which is of course the typical
cryptographic relaxation of information
theoretic security we can get a better
results we can get security in some
sense at least under standard
cryptographic assumptions for any T so
security against any strict subset of
colluding parties and as I said before
this is impossible in the standard
information theoretic model I should
mention that the standard information
theoretic model assumes the existence of
secure point-to-point channels and
possibly broadcast channel so it's tight
right we cannot get it with information
theoretic security but several
augmentations of the standard model that
allow for information theoretic security
even when there is no honest majority
for instance popular a extension is
assuming the existence of oblivious
transfer another is the existence of
some trusted set up phase that might be
implemented using offline pre-processing
given which the protocol can achieve
information-theoretic security against
an arbitrary number of parties and just
know this oblivious transfer it's
referred to also as the OT hybrid model
assumes the availability of an ideal to
party quarrel between any pair of
parties that can take a pair of strings
from one party called the sender in a
selection bid from a second party called
the receiver and deliver only the
selected string to the receiver without
revealing anything else to the receiver
or anything about the selection to the
sender okay this is what I mean by
augmenting the standard model with
oblivious transfer we give this ideal
oblivious transfer between any pair of
parties ok so again this is still at the
informal level get more formal later in
the talk as far as the efficiency is
concerned the situation is more complex
first because we have several different
efficiency measures that sometimes are
in tension with each other we can refer
to communication rounds coming up
computation randomness non results are
more sensitive to the exact flavor of
security again I will talk extensively
about the flavors of security we have
but efficiency results tend to be more
sensitive naturally to the type of
security we require it's a very active
area of research I should say that
compared to other areas of the crypto it
has a relatively small gap between the
best between those results we can prove
under even under standard very standard
assumptions versus the best solutions
are the most efficient solutions we
don't know how to break right this is
heuristic efficiency is the efficiency
of the best solutions we don't know how
to break in this area we tend to have to
kind of have the privilege of not having
to deal with these situations where we
have a great solution but we don't know
how to prove it under any standard
assumption this happens less often than
in most other areas of crypto and
perhaps in part for this reason this
area
you know it has a very I think very very
strong synergy between the theory I
don't want to say practiced because it's
still not deployed but really a lot of
implementation efforts and actual
companies that are selling these types
of protocols so this is now and we'll
hear about it in the next workshop I
believe there will be several talks that
deal with actual implementations and
concrete efficiency of MPC so you know
when I refer to efficiency in this talk
again this is a serial rented talk
referring to asymptotics but part of the
motivation of even finding different
ways or asking certain theory questions
right that's a very broad thing right
why do we care why are we obsessed so
much about you know to rehearse in three
rounds or all these things I think that
part of the reason is that these
challenges that are mostly theoretical
challenges they force us to think of new
ways to solve problems in these new ways
might yield the unexpected return and
also help perhaps less directly but help
those who care about the practice so
again I think that in this area there is
a very good match between theory and
practice I think that in part because a
lot of most of the results have the core
which is information theoretic or almost
information theoretic or maybe uses what
we function and then on top of it and
you can make this the bottleneck so you
can in many cases you can amortize the
way the part where we do have the gap
between proofs and heuristics and in the
in the domain in the information
theoretic domain we have a tighter
understanding or it a better match
between not being able to attack
something to find an actual break and
being able to prove that it works so I
think this is maybe the high level
reason and again it's not a universal
truth but I think it's it's true to a
large extent yes
you know your thing at the beginning
that the embassies everything didn't say
everything just complexity theory and
algorithms and yeah like not humanities
as far as I know but no I agree I what
I'm referring here I said I restricted
myself to secure function evaluation and
yeah you're absolutely right so the art
certainly fragments of MPC to which this
does not apply just because you can cast
also those areas but very good point
what I'm saying mainly is about this
whole business of implementing secure
function evaluation which is what also
you know it's about the type of the
constraints you're imposing right so in
practice sometimes same Theory you want
to minimize communication but
practitioners will tell you
communication is not the bottleneck you
need to minimize computation but again I
maybe I went a bit too far in this claim
but at least this is this has been my
experience in my research there were
very few things that you know I wanted
them to be secure and I could not you
know or they could not be food to be
secure relatively few things it's just
about mainly about my experience but
they think it also reflects on these
implementation efforts are very few
compromises people need to make people
implement the MPC you know sometimes
they resort or are the workers but but
this is to just to get to some kind of a
minor improvements not very big ones
typically
I mean if you look at the eye alright so
you could make a heuristic leap of faith
and assume that your eye always an ideal
obfuscation and now you can get all the
placate the beautiful applications that
they were heard about really so I will
mention so again every every problem has
its own heuristics but I'm just saying
this is the kind of general claim that
is consistent with what I know about
most of the things I've done and things
that people who implement protocol -
okay so right so so you know I guess
that you don't have to tell you about
this really ideal for paradigm which has
been a very powerful idea that probably
originated from the seminal work on a
probabilistic encryption and then zero
knowledge and then the first works of
MPC ending with with the UC framework
and and this part I am tells us that in
order to define security we don't try to
enumerate a list of security properties
which is both tedious and incomplete but
instead we just try to make the general
statement that we have some ideal
solution in mind the one we are
axiomatically happy with namely it's a
solution the previous solution using kim
right did you send all inputs to the
trusted party via minions back all the
outputs this is the type of solution
we're willing to live with and now we
want our actual distributed solution
that does not involve it wasn't party to
be as secure or in other words any
attack that exists again the protocol he
has a matching attack that achieves
something similar when attacking the
ideal implementation and by achieve what
I mean by achieve achieve contains two
types of things also there are
interactions between them but
essentially we're talking both about the
secrecy of data so learning
secrets of other parties and also about
correctness being able to influence and
this is relevant only when the attacker
the address sir is active if it's
passive then we only care about a
secrecy and this type of intuition can
be captured formally as we had the
notion of a simulator which again
captures both secrecy or privacy
correctness and also more subtle things
like independence of inputs right we
don't know we don't want the input of
the adversary to be to depend in some
way on the inputs of the honest parties
so we want to formalize this we have
this adversary that attacks the real
protocol so the adversary just corrupts
the set of parties and interacts with
all these parties the poorest parties
also talk with each other but the main
point that I care about is the
interaction between the adversary in the
oldest parties by the way people know
who this guy is I guess that Israelis
should but this is a famous Israeli is
like a parapsychologist or someone who
claims to have supernatural powers and
this is the skeptic his arch-nemesis who
is basically claiming this is the
simulator what is claiming is that you
know it's like there are all these
hackers that brag that they can break
you know they can break everything they
want okay you know whatever you achieved
by breaking by supposedly breaking the
protocol I can do in this deal
implementation all right so if you can
figure out that the input of some honest
part is bigger than seven right maybe
because the function allows us to
compute the millionaire's it problem
right so you can do it also in the ideal
model right so I can do it as well well
if you can bend a spoon this is what
this is a trademark I can do it as well
you know so the simulator basically is
telling the adversary that he has no
edge over what can be done by attacking
the ideal implementation right and we
also need to cop
the influence of the adversary on this
part is it's not enough to look at so if
we only considered what the adversary so
without loss of generality we can just
consider everything that way so you can
see right so if we only require that
this what what the adversary can see is
the same or essentially the same as what
the simulator can generate right the
simulator doesn't see it's very boring
the simulators world is very boring so
he needs to make up for what he doesn't
a the stuff he doesn't see so if we only
require that this is distributed the
same as this then this only captures the
secrecy right what the adversary learns
if we want to also capture influence of
the adversary then we also need to look
at the outputs of the honest parties in
both of these games and we need to
consider these two distributions jointly
so we can look at correctness alone so
it's this equal to this it's our privacy
alone it this is distributed the same is
this correctness alone is this is equal
is distributed the same as this but the
actual definition requires that the
Joint Distribution of these two is the
same as the Joint Distribution is this -
of this - and this is strictly stronger
than you know requiring separately both
privacy and correctness I mean each of
these notions alone is very problematic
it does not compose and so on so we
really must consider the two things
together okay and it's convenient to
formalize this using this notion of an
environment which serves as a kind of a
referee to see whether you know they are
really the same and we say that the
protocol is secure if no environment the
goal of the environment is to output a
bit and you know the protocol is
insecure if the environment can have a
significant advantage in distinguishing
between these two a protocol so these
two interactions and and and and what
the environment can do it can pick a
inputs you know for the oldest parties
it can interact with the adversary or
the simulator it does not know who it is
interacting with but its interaction
with the honest parties is restricted to
picking inputs and receiving outputs
and in their net output some bit and we
say that the protocol securely realizes
F for every adversary there is a
simulator such that no environment can
distinguish between the left side and
the right side and we have an important
distinction between the standalone case
again I'm being here bit simplistic but
one of the crucial differences between
the standalone setting for NPC and the
universally composable setting is that
in the standalone case the environment
basically lets only active in the
beginning and in the end so in the
beginning it picks inputs and sends them
to you know the earliest part isn't
address serene in the end it takes
outputs from the on from the adversary
or the simulator in the earliest parties
in the useless setting which we'll talk
a bit more about later the environment
can interactively interrogate the
adversary or the simulator in order to
distinguish between them in particular
distant forces what is known as
straight-line simulation okay there's
actually too many you know the now I'm
going to get in more details about
different variants of MPC and they're
actually more variants of MPC than we
want but the good news is that most
natural questions are not too sensitive
to the distinction between these models
there are several important distinctions
but most of the distinctions are
unimportant from the point of view of
most natural question we have many
different ways of you know transferring
results from one model to another and
also the community is kind of converged
to a small number of standard models so
it's not as if you know you can write a
new paper for every combination of the
parameters that they will specify next
okay but now I do want to give some
overview of the different variants of
definitions of MPC so when you want to
define a concrete MPC model you need to
specify or a concrete NPC tasks whether
the model you need to specify a
functionality which tells you what it is
that you want to achieve
network model that tells you you know
how parties can talk to each other what
the adversary can do so this tells us
how we're going to do it
right sorry the adversaries belongs to
the adversary so you need to define what
the adversary can do who it can corrupt
how many parties it can corrupt in what
way it can corrupt parties and we need
to specify security type which kind of
quantifies in a way what level of
protection we get or what kind of
protection we'll be ok functionality as
I said it captures the ideal goal and
specify the solution using a trusted
party and sometimes we put into the
functionality also some inevitable
vulnerabilities all right so it's not
always exactly what we want sometimes we
know we cannot get what we want so we
modify the functionality to get the next
best thing which might be realizable so
typically when people talk about secure
function evaluation they think about the
non reactive functionality which is the
mapping from a k1 of inputs the capital
of outputs there is also a more general
a case and very important and useful for
instance if you want to capture
commitment and similar primitives you
need to talk about reactive
functionalities which you can think of
it as an actual algorithm that has state
information and it can really interact
with the parties in multiple rounds for
the case of non reactive functionalities
which will be the focus of almost all of
the top there is a distinction between
deterministic and randomized there is a
distinction between the case of a single
output that is known to all or to one
party versus multiple part outputs which
is the case denoted here and and the
various standard ways of moving from so
if you have in the list if you have a
protocol that works in the least general
model say deterministic single output
you can easily extend it using standard
techniques perhaps with some loss of
efficiency but you can easily extend it
to the most general
reactive randomized multiple output so
it's Lanie for giving us a language to
express the things we want in a better
way as I said we sometimes augmented
functionality to capture some
vulnerabilities we are willing to
tolerate either because we have to or
because we don't know whether we need to
write a paper so for instance a common
relaxation is to allow the functionality
to receive input from an adversary so
specifying some allowable influence or
information that the adversary can learn
beyond just the output of corrupted
parties which it can always learn and
let me stress that the question of is it
a good idea to compute this
functionality securely it's not an
obvious one because also in this ideal
solution the adversary does learn
information right if we compute the sum
function and adversary you know corrupt
five out of the six people then you can
completely figure out how much travel
support the poor guy is receiving so so
the question of which functionality is
safe to compute it's really out of scope
for this token in general for the area
of NPC and this is precisely the scope
of differential privacy which Cynthia
will talk about tomorrow so this is
actually a common misconception people
think that yeah if you apply NPC then it
makes security problems go away and this
is very far from being the case
sometimes analyzing the security of
solutions that involve a trusted party
that's really the main issue
very good very good yeah this is really
you know a trade the best example for
why these things are useful okay so
Network model there is a distinction
between synchronous and asynchronous in
the standalone model most of the body of
research works in the synchronous model
in the two-party case there is no issue
so much but in the multi-party case
somehow the research of MPC is almost
entirely converged in the standalone
case to talk about synchronous
communication how realistic it is I
really don't know I guess that reality
is in between the a synchronous model is
too pessimistic the synchronous model
might be bit optimistic but I guess that
you can use timing or other things to
enforce or to approximate synchronous
communication there is a distinction
between secure point-to-point channels
versus open channels in the information
theoretic setting we always assume a
secure point-to-point channels unless we
allow a more powerful stuff like
oblivious transfer correlated randomness
a CENTAC ated versus unauthenticated
communication and we assume here that
everything is authenticated a full
network versus partial network and as I
mentioned we have these helper
functionalities like oblivious transfer
broadcast you know a lot of work on a
crypto using or NPC using noisy channels
and something that's very very important
in the context of your series is
something some flavor of a series common
reference string or common random string
a that is needed for many applications
okay the adversary we need to specify
something called an adversary structure
which tells us which sets of parties the
adversary can corrupt
typically we just look at the simple
case of a specialty of corrupted number
of corporate parties but
in almost all cases these results can be
generalized to more general types of
adversary structures there is a big
distinction between the case of an
honest majority vs. no honest majority
again the information theoretic setting
is really the main reason but also in
the computational setting there are
differences between what can be achieved
in both cases a big distinction is
between the passive or also known as
semi honest adversary that follows the
protocol it's like a virus that doesn't
want to be detected so it doesn't modify
the behavior of corrupted parties but it
does observe other information versus
active which can do anything there's
also some intermediate notions like
always looking and so on but these are
the main notions and another important
distinction is between assuming the
adversary to be bounded usually
polynomial time versus a completely
unbounded adversary which can do any
computation finally there is a question
of how corrupted parties are picked so
there is a static model where they need
to be picked in advance before the
protocol begins the adaptive model which
says that the adversary can dynamically
corrupted parties as long as it never
corrupts more than T parties in mobile a
model captures the situation where the
adversary can move corrupted parties as
long as at any point in time at most T
are corrupted okay so security type as I
said big distinction between standalone
and you see a quality of simulators so
the distinction between standalone and
UC is quite pervasive I will not get to
all of these details but essentially the
standard UC definitions today are quite
long and the standalone definitions are
quite concise so the UC model involves a
lot of things which aim to capture very
general situations the quality of
simulator can be perfect versus
statistical versus computational when I
said that the environment cannot
distinguish I did not say you know how
powerful is the environment and and how
how much do these output bit
can differ so in the perfect case
environment is unbounded and you're not
distinguished at all in a statistical
case it can have a negligible advantage
in distinguishing and still it's
unbounded and in the computational case
its usual notion of computational
indistinguishability simulator simulator
can also be bounded unbounded or
something is between between that is
also useful in some cases typically for
the purpose of this talk simulators are
always roughly as efficient as
adversaries and in terms of output
delivery again this is something that
could be captured by the functionality
by relaxing the functionality but
sometimes it's just convenient to
specify the functionality in a simple
way so it's a mapping from K inputs to K
outputs and then when there is no honest
honest majority we we cannot achieve
this notion of full security in general
full security means that everybody
receives the output right so in the case
of an honest majority even if we settle
for computational security there are
this impossibility results at our
mention later and so there are all these
relaxed notions fair security means that
either everyone gets the output or
nobody gets the output so the adversary
can basically disrupt everything but
then it doesn't learn anything the kind
of a standard notion for the stand alone
and also in a sense in the UC model is
so-called security with the board which
means that the adversary can learn the
output and then decide whether the
correct output will be delivered to the
honest parties or not so it gives the
adversary some unfair advantage and
there is some stronger notion which is
security with identifiable abort which
means that in the event that the
adversary decides to abort it must
sacrifice some corrupted party by
revealing its identity to the onus
parties actually the sillies will give a
talk later today which will mention
these notions it's not as well known
okay so the setting of
information-theoretic security just to
put it within these previous criteria so
we're talking about an unbounded
adversary important distinction between
active and passive we will assume an
honest majority with point-to-point
channels or a ot or curl or correlated
randomness in a sense you can think of
an auto key Oracle is a special type of
correlated randomness there are secure
point-to-point channels and broadcast if
we have an active adversary so there is
this boundary where we need to simple
cast we cannot get it information sea
radically if there are less than one
third of the of the parties are
corrupted then we can even realize
broadcast using point-to-point channels
and the security is typically but not
always so people identify information
theoretic security or in general with
unconditional security this is not
necessarily the case so there are quite
a few unconditional information
theoretic results which are conditional
just because we cannot prove I mean it's
not it's not very common but there are
still quite a few such results there
might be you know if we managed to prove
that you know one we functions exist we
might have unconditional computational
results so this is this point and you
know one nice thing about talking about
information theoretic security is that
it usually again not always but almost
always it also these protocols tend to
be universally composable and also
adaptively secure okay so the there is
some work by I'll telling you that that
shows that in some special cases you can
actually prove that information
theoretic security implies you see
security well it's not the case in
general but but almost all natural
protocols which are information
theoretic secure are also adaptively
secure in in you see secure so that's a
nice bonus for working in information
theoretic model including the case where
we have no honest majority so we have
two-party protocols used öto correlated
randomness in their natural they will
always be you see secure ok composition
is a major sin in MPC research it's been
really the topic of many many many works
I believe it was a kind of pioneered by
by Rankin et even though there are many
earlier attempts but today only run
survived basically the last man standing
yes we're actually a lot of earlier
efforts but today I think that the works
of one on UC security are the most well
known in the context of composition so
the goal of the composition or the
composition theorem takes the following
form
it says that if we have a protocol that
can be proved that we can prove that it
is secure for F but it needs to call
some subroutine some Oracle G right
which is an ideal functionality right so
we have this physical implementation we
deal functionality like an ideal
subroutine which the protocol can column
given this Oracle it can securely
realize F and now we have some other
implement and actual implementation of
this function functionality G by an
actual protocol ok so this is PI of F
given G this is PI G it securely
realizes G then what is the natural
thing to do to take every Orkin call in
the first protocol and replace it by an
execution of this inner protocol for G
right it's like taking a subroutine :
and replacing it by the actual code of
the subroutine and we expect why this is
true for subroutines we expect the
result to work by the protocol to be
secure unfortunately this is not always
the case
but let me first explain why this is
such an important question it has two
types of motivation first motivation is
looking outwards it ensures that if we
prove that the you know our protocol is
secure under composition it means that
you can safely plug it in some
higher-level application and think of it
as e for analyze it is if you have any
deal piece of hardware
that computes this function right this
is much easy easier than getting into
the the internals of the protocol and in
a different motivation which is actually
not less important even though you know
maybe originally this was the main
motivation so composition I think that
nowadays when people try to actually
build a lot of protocols and they care
about efficiency it's becoming super
important to design protocols in a
modular way and this is important for
the same reason and more that code is
built in a modular way so you can
analyze different components separately
you can optimize each component
separately if you optimize one component
then all applications that use this
component can benefit from these
optimizations so it's really hard to
overestimate the importance of this for
protocol design so in particular
something that's very useful is an exact
this is an example of this is assuming
an OT Oracle so you know even though
initially I motivated it as a way to get
information theoretic security actually
nowadays most of the implementations
they make extensive use of OT so they
think they analyze their protocols in
the OT hybrid model and then they can
plug in because of composition theorems
they can plug in some very efficient
implementations of OT right so so this
is very useful and is actually being
used in protocols that are being
implemented
so they standalone definition that as I
said are much simpler they can support
some kind of composition but this is
sequential composition it means that you
cannot make these two subroutine calls
concurrently you need to make one and
then once it's done once the execution
completes you can execute the other
which is good but not in many cases not
good enough and the the UC model
supports a general concurrent
composition unfortunately we cannot
realize UC security for many useful
functionalities or most useful
functionalities we cannot realize them
you see securely without any kind of
setup and there's
a lot of work on understanding what
types of relaxations are realizable as I
said before in the case where we have an
honest majority then we can realize you
see security with no setup other than
the existence of secured charge which
can also be realized you see securely
using PKI or okay so let me just recap
until now I talked about feasibility I
defined the I gave different
definitional variance and the
feasibility question is can we realize
you know a given functionality in a
given model so even though the
high-order bits have been settled I
guess for for quite a long time there
are many many many remaining questions
and I will just give some examples of
popular lines of research there are many
other lines of research to talk about
feasibility in certain maybe less
studied NPC models one type of very
popular recent line of research is this
revisiting the fairness question so
there is this classical result of cleave
that says that we cannot do coin tossing
and as a result say we cannot compute
XOR of two bits fairly in this created
the misconception that you know almost
nothing can be done fairly or that very
few useful things can be computed fairly
and in the breakthrough work of gordo
retal initiated the line of research
that attempted to to understand which
functionalities can be realized fairly
without an honest majority so now we're
at the state this is just a recent TCC
paper by this paper gives the full
characterization for the case of
two-party deterministic functionalities
that output a single bits to the same
part the same bit to two parties so
that's a special of special special case
which took a lot of effort to figure out
yes oh so it's two party functionalities
that are deterministic the output a
single bit and the same bit is is output
to the two parties so this case under
finite right they have review the
constant size input so this case has
been solved recently tons of other cases
we are in a somewhat similar a bit
better situation in terms of
understanding which functionalities can
be computed with information theoretic
security actually this is a line of
research that was initiated by by L and
this was before Joe Yale and Beaver
actually had the first works on
characterizing the two party case and
there has been really also a large body
of work trying to complete this
characterization and the latest is work
people in the audience you're a magic
man or animate a who completed this
characterization for the case of finite
non reactive functionalities you
increase finite meaning that the domain
size abuse is constant you increase the
domain side and again these are not just
a hypothetical questions so for instance
let me ask the following question can
you design a small hardware token given
which you can get information theoretic
obfuscation right so you can cast this
instance of the general question or you
know you can there are whole lines of
work say on crypto based on hardware
tokens that if we had these general
characterization for functionalities
that are big then these things would
follow in special cases but our theory
is not nearly developed enough to
capture all these useful cases beyond
what we know and even this is quite
hairy so this is really summarizes
totally has been involved here as well
and I guess that other people in the
audience possible security again Halle
lie
you know Rafael here meet my nose it's
been involved in lots of works on trying
to find creative new ways for getting
around impossibility results and yeah so
I will not say a lot about it but I'm
sure we will hear about it in later
talks both in this workshop and in the
next one one last thing I want to
mention so I think that one of the
challenges this is not really an open
well-defined open question but I think
that the main issue at least I'm having
with UC security mates it's a great
notion and we want everything to be
analyzing this framework but it's too
complex I mean if you try to tell you
know mathematician tells you you know
you you have a theorem right claiming
this protocol you see secure please
write down the complete statement of the
theorem you cannot do it you can refer
to pages and pages of definitions that
refer to each other so there has been a
so there is an upcoming a crypto paper
by a kinetic al that proposes some
simpler version of the UC model which
captures it's more restricted in scope
than the general UC model it's it's it's
in a good direction but at least
skimming it I feel that it still leaves
a lot to be desired so I think that
Julie Mayer has some ideas in how to do
it right I think that really this is an
important endeavor to get a version of
the of the UC framework that captures
the essence maybe it's not generally
enough to capture or we live situations
but it's enough to capture the essence
and eliminate all the noise right a lot
of what is done in UC proofs is noise
it's not that doesn't have to do with
the essence yes you can write a
self-contained definition in a few lines
I mean you can look at gold wax book
makes standalone definitions are very
easy
even if you talk about just and
composability it's very easy yeah yeah
yeah so I'm saying that in in the again
many of these things are just a matter
of taste or choice whether to be general
or be succinct but those who favor so
again as Amit said if you look at even
vivid bits problematic but if you
consider ideal obfuscation just a little
functionality then composition no and I
think that my response if you want to
take the current IO candidates and use
them suppose they were practical so you
could just assume this is an ideal
obfuscation as opposed to way beyond
frustration and then you don't have to
deal with I mean again it's not an ad
location but you make the leap of faith
you analyze the protocols as if it's
ideal application and then you don't
need to deal with composition issues for
food station you should refer the
question to those who understand the
question more than me but but I mean
just taking a mid word I think that
there is no good theory of composing
below food station right yes so my nose
you will talk about it in the okay very
good
all right and finally a yeah I guess
that this will be a good time to take a
break right how much when is my hour
over in a few moments okay good I'll
continue a bit so finding new ways for
driving feasibility results so the
second part of my talk will be mostly
about showing different ways to get
feasibility results why do we need to
get yet more ways and
reasons one sometimes what we have is
not simple enough right if you look at
the textbook like definition it's a
textbook proof of the gmw protocol from
say gold wax book it's still not not
short and not elegant it's not something
you really believe is the right I mean
the intuition is always very clear and
simple we have good intuition in mind
but for some of the protocols but there
is a gap between how simple we feel this
should be and how simple it really is
when you need to write down the
protocols in the book so finding new
ways and simple ways it could
potentially makes things better but also
this relates to a point I made before a
when we look at efficiency then finding
being forced to find new ways they will
always be better in some settings so
whenever you have a different solution
to a problem there will always be
setting where this different solution
will win and give you better things so I
think that nowadays the interest of the
[ __ ] in the practical efficiency of MPC
also further motivates finding new ways
to solve old problems ok so let's take a
break